well thank you yes i'm also going to be
back in these trucks
[Music]
when we discuss taxation this was always
opposed to rich's higher taxes that
again is proper conservatism and i think
she's got the character to lead the
party in the nation
is liz trust the stop rishi candidate
liz trust is the best candidate that's
what we're working for she's a proper
eurosceptic she'll deliver for the
voters and she believes in low taxation
thank you woman
and is she is she's a continuity
candidate will boris johnson be backing
her up
so that was uh the culture secretary
nadine doris and the brexit minister
jacob rees-mogg they have just announced
that they are backing liz trusts to
become the next leader of the
conservative party and by extension the
next prime minister ali khan ford's girl
political correspondent was listening to
that ali what did you make of that
well there we go jacob rees-mogg the
brexit minister nadine doris the culture
secretary both backing liz trust i think
that makes liz trust the candidate of
the right of the party the continuity
candidate in a sense the one that boris
johnson loyal this will rally around and
i asked them you know is she the stop
rushing candidate and i think that is
really what she is going to become now
because we have seen i mean nadine doris
has been pretty clear in her criticism
of the former chancellor and his
decision this time last week to resign
ending really boris johnson's
premiership triggering the collapse of
government and the swathe of resignation
among junior ministers and they've just
come out they've said they're going to
be endorsing liz trust until now um what
we're really seeing is candidates like
liz trust like kevin baden or like swell
of briverman and pretty patel if she
does um stand sort of fishing
from the same pond getting um
mps from the right of the party to back
them people like
steve baker um people like michael gove
we've it is interesting to see the the
votes split in a sense so i think what
we're seeing now is boris johnson
loyalists um gathering round um liz
truss and she of course has um pitched
herself as a tax cut in contrast to the
chancellor the former chancellor uh
rishi sunak who's facing criticism for
not being willing to tax to cut taxes
quickly enough she suggested and that
she'd want to
reverse the national insurance hike
that's meant to pay for social care and
health care so there we go two of those
big beasts in boris johnson's cabinet
his
favorite supporters right till the last
coming out and backing liz trust but of
course we are expecting rishi sunak at
any moment now not far from here to
launch his bid at the moment he has the
most mps openly backing him and of
course today is a crucial day because
what they need is 20 nominations from
mps other than themselves to get onto
that ballot paper tomorrow so a
forwarder second and 18 other mps
backing them that is what they're going
to be trying to do it seems as if
quite a few of those candidates will get
through already it looks like people
like tom tugan penny mordant and rishi
sunak all have the numbers and i suspect
after this intervention this morning we
will almost certainly see
liz trust getting on that ballot paper
tomorrow and mps of course will be
voting tomorrow and we'll see the number
of candidates being whittled down really
quite quickly it could even be um that
by next week we are already down to the
final two
ali obviously uh our colleague beth
rigby spoke yesterday to boris johnson
he declined to uh swing behind any of
the candidates but jacob reese morgan
nadine doris were really two of his
closest and most loyal confederates you
know they were in the bunker with him in
his in the dying days before he
announced he was resigning can we see
this as an by extension an endorsement
from boris johnson for his trust
i think it's probably fair to say um i i
mean yesterday as you say
beth rugby couldn't get an answer out of
boris johnson he he wouldn't say who he
would back he's obviously an
unconventional prime minister i wonder
further down the line we will see him
more openly backing a candidate but at
the moment he is not doing that but i
think having two of those people that
right till the end was standing with
boris johnson when so many people
abandoned him having them coming out
outside downing street after cabinet and
saying that they support liz trust i
think you have to see that as by an
extension and endorsement from boris
johnson